I wanna just ask some advice and selfishly take a moment.
I never, when we were younger and single and free,
and like, just, you know, getting started,
revving our engines,
and I never knew that we would be sitting here.
I know, right?
And I would be asking like, talk show advice.
That's crazy, right?
Not only are we parents, we both have talk shows.
I mean, what did you, what have you learned
since day one of the show until now?
What's like the overarching aha moment,
that may have taken years to learn,
but now you know?
I think people don't wanna watch you as a host
stress in real time about how the show's going,
because in the early days of the show,
every monologue joke that didn't work.
I feel like the audience could see on my face, like, ugh.
And I just don't think, especially when you're watching
a show like mine at 12:30 at night,
they don't wanna see some host
white knuckling it threw a monologue.
And so it's just like giving myself the permission
to be comfortable with it and know that not everything
is going to be the best joke people have ever heard,
but that there'll be humor in watching maybe the worst joke
they've ever heard go badly in a room full of people.
And so that is a thing that, you know,
I think Carson did better than anyone, Johnny Carson,
and then second place Carson Daly.
I was on his many times.
Yeah I cannot believe it, that's the craziest thing.
It was 1982 Carson.
And then I did a show many times.
That's amazing.
How many times do you think you did Johnny Carson?
Probably five, six, seven.
And I also did it with Joan Rivers
and Jay Leno when they would sub in for him.
Okay, so what are your favorite segments of your show now?
Well, you know,
we have this segment called 'The Closer Look'.
My favorite.
That is like 15 minutes, 12 to 15 minutes every day.
And it's just so nice to know that's gonna be
the sort of, the meat of our show,
and the the biggest part of our writing any day.
And it just helps us, you know, process the news of the day.
And then we do sillier things.
We did a thing last night that's sort of new
called 'Surprise Inspection'
where we read all the worst monologue jokes
that our writers turned in over the course of a month.
Oh my God!
And they don't know they're doing it.
And we show their pictures and,
they're mostly like just terrible puns
or massively offensive.
And that's a very fun thing to do.
(audience laughing)
(audience applauding)
Okay, there's another segment that people love
called 'Day Drinking'.
Yeah, 'Day Drinking'.
I used to be a huge day drinker.
I liked partying early and ending early.
Yeah.
So, Rihanna did 'Day Drinking' with you,
18 million views this has.
Yeah.
What was that like?
I think 9 million are for me and 9 million are for you.
(audience cheering)
It was an exceptional, it was an exceptional afternoon.
She's a really wonderful down to earth person.
And she was really,
it was great to afternoon booze with her,
I gotta say.
Oh my God, what a bucket list dream come true.
Also, the other thing is I, this, I think,
speaks to the fact that I'm older than Rihanna.
At the end of that, I went home and fell asleep
in my hallway, outside my apartment door.
And I'm pretty sure she went out, yeah.
And like, started a new business.
Oh yeah, right.
She went out to like have like,
meetings with like Angel investors.
Yeah.
(cheerful music)